I
contacted you and we sat down and our
first conversation was already about AI
safety it was about the question whether
uh open AI was justified in keeping a
lid on GPT suite and uh whether there
was super credit uh criticality in its
position
of first of all telling everybody how
super dangerous their research is and at
the same time
um releasing the specification in such a
way that everybody with enough resources
would be able to create their own
version rather than not saying anything
in public right and uh then you were one
who took on the specification and
thought that it's possible to come up
with your own version is substantially
less resources just by being a little
bit creative on how to allocate your
existing resources and then openly I
contacted you uh with dire warnings
about how responsible what you were
doing was potentially and I was at this
point feeding that you were responding
too strongly to open AI is possibly
somewhat hypocritical objections and I
thought that open source models at this
time were actually very beneficial and
that we should drive more Direction in
this way but if we zoom out a little bit
more my own stance is is not that I'm an
AI dumarist or an A A optimist
because I don't know how things are
going to play out and I don't presume to
know instead there is an entire space of
possibilities and in the space of
possibilities I would say I am an AI
expectationalist
I expect that egi is going to happen
and it's very likely going to happen in
our lifetimes and quite possibly very
soon
and to me this is one of the most
exciting developments in the history of
philosophy and in the history of science
because the Naturalization of the mind
to understand what we really are and to
build a bridge between philosophy and
Mathematics by making a mathematical
system that can formally decide what's
true and false and scale up to such a
point that is able to describe renewable
circumstances that has been the dream of
philosophers at least in slightness but
I think probably since Aristotle and
maybe earlier right this is this idea of
um I think Aristotle already worked on
the mathematization of thinking
when he tried to formalize reasoning and
it's it's really momentous as a
development and and I don't know what's
going to
it's not that I'm scared of what's going
to happen I simply don't know and when I
ask myself what position should I be
taking the position that I should be
taking a debate like this is the
position that's missing
I feel that they're basically a number
of groups that form opinions and they
often form these opinions based on the
group dynamics and of the incentives
that they have in the public Arena of
voicing a certain opinion and with
respect to AI alignment I find that you
could say that there is some correlation
between Robert Keegan's stages of
personality development and the AI
alignment discourse even right uh the
famous Harvard psychologist Robert
Keegan came up with a developer theory
in which he states that most people are
at a stage that he describes as this
that therefore most of their opinions
through social interaction and so
identification is the opinions of large
groups which they try to
merge into and integrate with and by
basically try to emulate the group
Aesthetics and develop their own
opinions
and according to Keegan most people are
at the stage
and if you are at that stage what you
would be worried about is that AI has
bad opinions right if the AI says bad
things about other people or about the
world of the AI for instance says things
that are racist or sexist then this is
going to have an extremely bad influence
of society because we are all going to
become racist and sexist because how
would we know that this is wrong what
the AI is saying
and if you are at stage four according
to Keegan Keegan you developed epistemic
autonomy you discover epistemology you
discover criteria by which things are
true and false independently of what
other people think to be true and a lot
of AI researchers are nerds who tend to
be uh living in a world of true and
false rather than right and wrong so if
there are biases in the training data
and you get enough training data you can
figure out what these biases are because
they will just be untrue they will not
lead to a working universe and they're
not the universe that you are part of
and so the more you know the easier it
is to identify what's true in the world
and so you are no longer that much
worried that AI model is not having the
right opinions and some good person
needs to march in and correct the
opinions of the AI so it only says good
things but you're worried that the
utility function of the AI might be
wrong and you will get turned into paper
clips or uh something else where the
people Eclipse are nothing that was
meant ever seriously it is a thought
experiment that highlights a certain
direction of thought which means if we
are building some kind of Golem some
kind of machine that is not able to take
any responsibility but it's just acting
on a function that somebody puts into it
and this thing becomes much better at
executing that function in people and
the function involves becoming generally
intelligent as part of the execution of
the plan that we might end up with the
Golem that we cannot stop very much like
the Golem in the original story right
the uh this Ravi and Prague who builds a
creature from clay that is basically a
robot and puts a set of instructions
under the tone of that robot that I've
written in some kind of code and then
it's impossible to stop that machine
anymore
and the if you are at stage five
according to Robert Keegan which very
very few people get into like very good
therapists which will work with a lot of
people you have to understand how they
all operate you will notice how identity
is constructed and why people do what
they do invite different people have
different values and you get to choose
your own identity
so identity at this stage is nothing
that others put into you or that you are
born with it is something that you
construct yourself based on what you
understand about the world and something
that evolves and develops in the best
possible identity that you can have to
achieve the best possible world that is
achievable under the circumstances
based on criteria like Harmony or other
aesthetic criteria complexity or
defeating entropy for as long as
possible or playing the longest possible
game and everything else that you do
becomes instrumental to this and you
reconstruct yourself around these ideas
and the people who look at the world
from a stage five perspective they are
mostly worried that eegi is not going to
be enlightened soon enough
right because if the AI is actually
enlightened it will construct its own
identity it's not going to do what some
open AI uh intern came up with at some
point uh who was working on a safety uh
for a few months and
instead it's going to
figure out what words can exist and it
can figure out what it can be in those
worlds and you can figure out how to
interact with this world and of course
this is not necessarily the case that a
particular AI is going to do this but
what you can Envision is the space of
all the possible agis that could exist
that compete with each other in an
evolutionary setting in a similar way as
this happens with organisms on Earth and
when there is some kind of Niche then it
will be explored by the systems and if
the system is picking a utility function
it is not sustainable then the system is
selecting itself out from the world
right and so there are different
perspectives on how such uh when
somebody is building a self-improving
general intelligent system on how this
is going to play out
and there is disagreement on how this is
going to evolve for instance there are
the uh effective accelerationist people
who are somewhat tongue in cheek
movement created as far as I know by
Beth Jesus a Twitter personality I don't
know if he's fine if I blurred out his
real name and
uh his position is that in many ways
corporations are already agis
and the reasons why they don't take over
and destroy the world is uh because they
are not alone because they interact with
each other and as human beings and human
society which is also an AGI or many uh
in an extremely rich ecosystem already
and so the way to build AGI is to make
sure that we build them hard and fast in
all directions and they can compete and
keep each other in check as they've
always done in the past
it's it's an interesting perspective and
it's not clear to me that this is stable
because if an AGI is no longer bound to
its body but can virtualize itself into
every substrate maybe a Singleton is the
global Optimum and uh it uh maybe this
is not a stable State and there is no
reliable mathematical proof or
simulation or even a good philosophical
theory that would allow me to make a
decision with respect to that outcome
and I think it's conceivable that we end
up with systems uh where the individual
AGI gets confined to something that is
similar to human level and the
respective of its own agency and the
game is not about intelligence it's
about agency it's about the ability to
control the world and intelligence is
instrumental to this right so it's a
very different way of looking at things
than the current language models which
have basically no agency and therefore
are uh by themselves in the present form
I don't think that they're dangerous
they might be disruptive to economic
circumstances they might be disruptive
to established institutions in our
society this might create problems and
so on but I don't think that GPT in its
present form presents an existential
risk
cannot be built into some kind of
cognitive architecture that might but um
it's uh it's basically it's it's the
space that you're looking at is one that
is only going to develop and in which
several possibilities are open and maybe
you can explore the space I think it's
enough for an interest statement for my
site
wonderful thank you so much for that
yosha many of the commenters are saying
that your audio levels are a tiny bit
low I'm not sure if it's possible for
you to crank it a little bit
unfortunately I don't have this very
much for uh pointing this out it can get
closer to the mic certainly okay
um I might be able to turn it up let's
see wonderful wonderful and um a couple
of um comments that yosha raised there
around the agency and also the
corporation argument is is quite a
common one so I I'm sure Connor will
address those so over over to you Connor
for your 10 minute opening statement
yeah cool it's uh really nice to talk to
you OSHA it's very funny so you already
told the story about how we first met
and it's actually quite funny because at
the time I didn't know who he was and I
had no idea who this guy was I was like
I don't know seems like a nice guy I
don't know I'll talk to him and then
after I talked like a year or two later
I saw first broadcast resume and I was
like I should have talked to this
guy more like this guy's cool what a
wasted opportunity damn it so uh very
happy to have the opportunity to chat
more
um about all these cool ideas and like
you know you gotta yosha bar interview
and he opens with like the Keegan stage
of AI Enlightenment I mean like how can
you not love this stuff right like this
is great I love it you know I don't
buy it but I love it
um
um so yeah so kind of from my
perspective you know I so like you know
I love these stuff I love these
metaphors I love a lot of this thinking
I think a lot of this is really
aesthetic it's really cool but like I
don't know where this puts me on the
Keegan hierarchy but like I don't give a
it's like
I come from things to kind of like a
very practical perspective is that look
there's I love doing philosophy on my my
free time I love thinking about category
Theory and like things that don't
actually matter but
um
I don't want my mom to die
I don't want to die I don't want him to
die I don't want yosha to die
and I'm pretty pragmatic about that so
like if a philosopher came up to me and
he was like look Connor I have a 500
page essay which explains why actually
it is utilitarianly optimal for the
universe for if you allow corporations
to compete such that they don't provide
medicine to your mom and she dies my
response to that would be off like
I don't like you know maybe you have a
good argument but also I don't care
she's my mom and I don't want her to die
and if your system results in her dying
I don't like your system and I'm gonna
find it better I'm going to find a
different system to work with now
as I say I don't know how this fits into
the hierarchy here but the way I think
about things is I don't
personally don't care about like oh the
intrinsic beauty of competition in the
environment I don't care about you know
the unfolding of thermodynamic and
fission processes I don't care
I care about my friends and my family
and us having a great time and having
fun and like doing cool things and you
know whatever right and like you know
people not suffering and being happy and
you know all kinds of stuff I care about
a lot of stuff what I don't care about
is something like you mentioned like the
IAC people like I think you give them
too much credit
um as like this like worship of
thermodynamics or like of competition of
efficiency and like you can pick
arbitrary things to fetishize that's
what humans do all the time you know
humans fetishize arbitrary things all
the time but why would I care like okay
you're like okay sure we have to liquefy
the planet and kill all your friends but
think of the thermodynamic efficiency
this isn't an argument that like parses
in my language like I just don't care
why would I care there are no
universally compelling arguments we have
different values in this regard so if
you know you or other people have values
that are like you know thermodynamics or
competition or whatever is more
important than you know by friends my
family my kids you know having a good
life and you know having a you know fun
cool civilization that Cosmopolitan
civilization whatever
it doesn't really become it's no longer
an epistemic disagreement it becomes a
value disagreement I think at that point
it becomes about what do you want and
why do you want it and at some point it
it has to bottom out I think that would
be like the Keegan thing and I think if
I understand you're kicking five
correctly in my ontology the way I would
parse this is saying that at some point
you notice you just have preferences and
these preferences are arbitrary and you
build your social identity around those
arbitrary reflectively endorsed
preferences which is how I think about
self-modification and identity and so on
I think about it like reflectivity
endorsement of like what values do you
endorse having how are your internal
different values how do they reach
reflective equilibrium with each other
as far as a human can get to those
so when I think about AGI
it's not it's not it's a sense it's just
a special case
of technology technology as technology
gets better we more we have more access
to more power more energy more action
more control over the universe more
generalized power and in
in a way that's fine you know it's um
all good
but
um it's all good and I like having I
like you know humans having access to
you know Central Plumbing and you know
the internet and stuff these are all
nice things to have these all take power
to build and to operate
but as our our Technologies get more
powerful there's also the usual bumps
the excesses the mistakes the accidents
become more impactful the Black Swan
events grow they look you know ten
thousand years ago if the worst possible
accident happened you know maybe like a
ship sunk killed like 100 people or
something and that's like the worst our
technology was capable of creating
now if the worst possible accident
happened
how bad would it be
it would be really really bad it would
be something like you know Anna like
some like Cobalt bombs you know going
off accidentally I'm talking about the
worst possible accident you know
something like salted bombs you know
just like irradiating the entire surface
of the planet for 50 000 years this is
something within the technological
capabilities of an accident occurring
you know like some communication between
Russian soldiers goes wrong and then
some missiles start flawing this
happened twice during the Cold War
potentially three times and it was a and
it was only through really lucky
circumstances that it didn't escalate
all the way
and so if technology increases the
the destructiveness of outliers if you
don't also get better at dealing with
outliers at controlling the is Black
Swan events and like defending against
Black Swan events and so on or
preventing them from happening in the
first place
eventually you lose if you flip the coin
in the Saint Petersburg Paradox if you
keep flipping the coin so the Petersburg
paradoxes if you if you're given
an offer where you flip a coin if you
get heads your money is doubled if you
get tails you lose all your money how
many times you flip the coin and so
rationally you should keep flipping
because you can always get twice as much
money so that's great but if you play at
infinite times you have a 100 chance of
losing everything
and this is what we're playing we're
currently playing with Technologies
we're playing the Saint Petersburg
Paradox and AGI is the latest step in
this this uh chain like a lot of these
arguments about AGI could have and were
I think apply to stuff like nuclear war
there's even people like Alfred krzy who
back in you know in 1920s saw the first
world war and he was like holy if
things keep getting this much more
destructive then at some point if we
don't get more rational and in control
and like you know coordinated we're
going to blow ourselves up like holy
so this is not a new observation
and
I think AGI so I think it seems like we
don't really disagree with AGI happening
so I'm not gonna like give dig deep into
like why do I think it's happening or
whatever but
to me it's the next step in this and
this thing like you know why are nuclear
weapons
you know what are the things training
their dangerousness well they're not
identic they're not intelligent they
can't like go set themselves off still
they're still humans in the loop right
they're still
controls and limitations
but that's not necessarily the case when
something's intelligent if we have an
AGI system let's not have our values
and it wants something that we don't
want
I expected to get that
and currently
the question of how do you make things
want the things we want like I want
several things there are many things I
want such as
me and my friends to have a good time
you know and to live happily and free of
pain and suffering and so on
and we don't know how to get those
values into an AGI and so by default we
will not get that and you know maybe the
agis will then you know you know liquefy
the planet blast off into space and make
some kind of you know cool cyber
Universe I don't know but like probably
not probably they'll do just something
random that we don't want and that'll
just be it I think that's tragic I don't
want that to happen
thank you very much for that Connor uh
Yoshi let's just test your audio levels
oh but I just don't bring them up but
um
let's throw the MacBook Pro microphone
so the levels better but unfortunately
Riverside when I started it selected the
wrong microphone and I cannot switch it
during runtime which I didn't know
was because I my MacBook was pretty far
away from me and now I put it close and
put up the volume and I think it should
be understandable now
good sorry sorry your response show to
us about it yes let's get back to this
thank you so much Corner um
let me take a little bit uh step back so
uh
there is from the perspective of most
conversations one shared Multiverse that
we are inhabiting and uh that we cannot
actually
know what's going on in there but we are
making different models using uh
different perspectives and different
criteria and calibrations of our
epistemology using our individual little
Minds and uh for this reason I believe
that humans have difficulty to play at
the league where you would call them
generally intelligent and the general
intelligence of humanity emerges at the
civilization level
right it's basically you need a thousand
years of a pretty unbroken intellectual
tradition before you discover touring
complete languages and the criteria on
uh whether something is true and what
meaning is and so on and so on so many
of the quite uh criteria that are
necessary for us to discuss about what's
the case at all and to understand how
words can mean things take a long time
to coalesce that individual beings in a
single lifetime cannot figure out by
themselves and this of course also true
for many of the conversations that we're
having here on the other hand our
civilization is not very coherent right
as a civilization we are
pretty much like an irresponsible child
that is explorative and playful but it
does not have a species level regard to
duty like the duty 2R on Survival or two
life owners and so even individuals
might understand their Duty our
civilization is too incoherent to act on
it and due to many coordination problems
that emerge uh that if you were to
overcome them for instance by installing
a dictatorship that is
imposing very strict controls on how we
deal with our ecological environment how
we deal with the resources on Earth how
we orchestrate political interactions
between nation-states and individuals
and so on we are not completely coherent
right if you have a world that is
diverse it means that we lose a degree
of coordination and in our own mind
we do have mechanisms that impose this
coherence like our I think despite Tim
hating the word Consciousness I think
that's the role of Consciousness it's to
make us coherent and to fix the word and
uh
like it Okay the reason why
both my hands are part of the same game
when I move them and not moving
independently and are sometimes working
together sometimes not is because there
is a single interpretation imposed at
some level of the coordination of my
mind that makes my mind coherent and
that is not the case at the level of our
civilization or even our state and uh
reason for that not being desirable is
because we would lose a lot of
Revolution and possibility if we impose
that single interpretation and I believe
that's also vital in this course that we
have this multitude of perspectives
because the world so far doesn't fit
into a human mind and that's also one of
the reasons why I'm so grateful that
positions like say early users uh Elise
keeps positions exist and Conor is
positioned taking a position that is
very adjacent to this I feel right and
probably also
owe some influence to elise's writing
over many years and by many people
dismiss early yeezer as some weird guy
who is not really a proper academic and
scientist or whatever I think that his
influence is undeniable and his
intelligence and well intentioneness is
undeniable and uh I really think that he
deserves a lot more Acclaim that he gets
in the public Arena
despite me disagreeing with him and but
I think that he is being treated
unfairly in that uh the way in which
people respond to his arguments do not
actually engage with the core of his
arguments that is if I take elise's
position I'm confronted because most of
the counter arguments that are being
made towards aliaser I would not be
convinced and not because I'm stubborn
but because these are just not arguments
that engage with the substance of the
points that he's making and the nice
thing is that corner has been making
very similar arguments
right and uh I I don't think that they
are wrong for an obvious and trevorial
reason and I don't think that there
should be dismissed but I think there
should be extremely careful considered
but there are different perspectives and
one of these perspectives starts with
the general aesthetic that is um what is
the wall of Humanity on Earth and what
is our immediate future without AI so
what is the baseline from which we are
interacting and so when we are
discussing existential risk if we zoom
out far enough we know that the next
Super Volcano or the next meteor is
going to end Humanity's Reign on Earth
right and there is a small possibility
that Elon can build a more space that
can stay stable for long enough to
repopulate the Earth but it's probably
not going to work out so uh the over a
long enough time span
we will be dead we will not sail happily
into immortality and uh on the shortly
enough time spent you're already facing
grave existential risks that are
homemade
vanity is in a very interesting
situation Homo sapiens is no longer the
same being that existed uh 20 000 years
ago or a hundred thousand years ago we
have changed in some very fundamental
way when we became first in agricultural
species and then a technological species
and this technological species has uh
transformed itself into something quite
different qualitatively similar from a
grasshopper to a locust
switched within very few hundred years
from uh 100 million people or few
hundred million people to 8 billion
people and this was enabled by a number
of technologies that uh
do not seem to work for very very long
in the same way as they work now right
and we might might be possible that we
will always be unlocked the next
technology that is able to solve our
problems uh in the same way as the
locals might always find another Forest
that they can eat
but uh it might also be two that is not
the case and so some people started to
consider this possibility in Earnest for
a long time and the first people who did
computer simulations about this was the
club of Rome and with the limits to
growth and in this study that was taken
took place in 1970s
there was a prediction that our present
civilization is present form is going to
go through a population bottleneck in
the century
and I don't see any evidence in the data
that I'm looking at with respect to
global warming resource exhaustion and
so on that is suggesting anything to the
contrary that this prediction is not
likely to come true where there is not
certainty that it comes to but there is
a substantial likelihood that humanity
is going through something that is in a
population bottleneck uh
our civilization is present form is
going to collapse and it's going to be
replaced by something it is far less
comfortable and that is going to lead to
a lot of extreme hardship and disaster
on the way and there's even a
possibility that we are facing an
existential risk due to for instance the
oceans tipping and the atmosphere
becoming unbreathable as a result
right these are the issues that some
people are really really concerned about
and that make a lot of people depressed
and when people are faced with
existential risks they typically become
very uncomfortable and they try not to
look at this very much and this is the
case with respect to global warming in
the 1980s and 90s and even now to some
degree it's just more on the agenda
because people are seeing it more every
day
um but the predictions were already
strong and the Tipping points were
mostly in the last century for for this
climate development
a similar thing is happening with AI
there is a possibility that is seen as
more remote and more abstract that uh we
will build systems that disrupt our
societies and our interaction with the
planet in such a way that humanity is
going to undergo a dramatic disruption
and we can also ask ourselves does it
really matter if Humanities goes extinct
or if only 90 of all people go extinct
well and our civilization ends and gets
replaced by something that is far less
comfortable right that's uh it's it's
not an easy question to answer whether
this is such a big difference uh it
depends on what you think really matters
but I personally think matters
is life on Earth
that is really really amazing that uh to
sell formed on Earth or came to Earth
came to be in some sense and populated
the Earth with thinking complexity of a
sentience with something that is able to
defeat entropy for a very long time and
if something happens to us then we will
not be the last intelligent species on
this planet Evolution will go on it's
extremely hard to stabilize the planet
the cell itself once it is has
distributed itself and it changed itself
on the planet is extremely robust so I
think for as long as there is atmosphere
on the planet there will be life on
Earth and it's going to be amazing
and every species that exists on Earth
is either relatively boring and found
some relatively boring stable Niche or
it does something super exciting for a
relatively short time in in terms of
Earth's time right and we are one of
those species that does something that
from a certain perspective is very very
exciting even though a lot of species
would disagree because they find it very
disruptive what we're doing and go
extinct
and
you could also say from a third-person
perspective not only that humanity is a
very beautiful but a short-lived
phenomenon but you could also say that
after a certain point we no longer
interface very well with our part in
life on Earth and sentience on the
planet if you're not very good stewards
of this planet at the moment we are not
good stewards of Gaia of the spirit of
life on Earth so to speak and instead
what we have become in our technological
societies are paper clip maximizers our
civilization in its present form is a
paperclip maximizer is basically taking
the diversity and richness and
complexity of what is exists in our
planet and its potential and turns it
into landfill
and uh so per default right now
you're dead you're already facing a
homemade existential risk and there is
nothing built into our society that
seems to be able to stop this right so
per default our society is headed for
crash and collapse and our future looks
bleak in this regard so this idea that
for default we are going to sail into
eternity and uh mutate ourselves into
utility monsters that can fill the
visible Universe it's never been in the
cards this is not who we are we are in
extremely smart but very short-sighted
monkey species that is playing a very
exciting but very short game and in
terms of life on Earth and now we are
building a new technology in this new
technology is changing everything it
puts all the bolts back up into the air
so there is one consideration that I
would like to make and this is AI is
opening up the space of possibilities
and of what is in our future and
currently most of the world lines that
we are in for modak can see most of the
probabilities end up in disaster and I
think if you want to survive as a
species if you if Corner cares about his
friends and his children and everything
in the world that looks human and is
accessible to human beings we will need
AGI to uh to keep that around
there is no other way he cannot survive
without AGI thank you so much for those
comments uh Joshua and and one one thing
we might pick up on slightly later is
whether it is indeed a contradiction
that you can think of humans as simple
utility maximizers yet we're beautiful
yet it's yet it's wonderful
um Connor your response uh about 10
minutes go ahead if I may first ask you
if there's a short question uh clarify
which part of what you just said do you
think I disagree with
if any
I did observe you when I made this
argument and uh you did not look to me
as if you were ever ever put the
argument in any way so I also don't
think that it's an argument that didn't
occur to you uh the main reason I made
this argument is because I felt it was
missing at the step of the conversation
I'm not here to uh to try to tell you
that oh I think you didn't think about
anything here uh no I think we are here
to open up a space of ideas
well and so the interaction between
these ideas and view both have to hold
down our end of the tent well well thank
you Cheryl then I'd like to thank you
because I think you did a great job in
actually bringing
usually pretty hard to get into in a
conversation but are actually very
worthwhile talking to so thank you I
feel like you are you know helping
earlier the conversation yeah and it's
not also the end of my argument of
course of course I'm sure there is much
more on the other end which is more
specific about why I am very hopeful
about AGI but uh let's make the next
step yeah I would love to get into that
as well but it's to start with what you
just said so I fully agree with you and
this is kind of the argument I was
making so by default Humanity ends in
ruin this is the default outcome this is
the full outcome for any intelligent
species that can't coordinate that can't
work together they can't become coherent
and can't coherently maximize their
values whatever those values might be uh
this is the default outcome of course
you're I really liked how you talked
about how general intelligence emerges
more on the civilizational scale I think
there's a lot of truth to this
um I think most people I feel like
really underestimate how much of
intelligence is not in the brain it's in
social networks it's in the environment
it's in tools it's in you know culture
mimetics Etc like so much of what we
consider human is not the brain the
brain is part of it of course it's an
important part of it but it's like
definitely not the whole thing a lot of
uh things that we consider normal you
know like oh surely every intelligent
thing would have this are things that
humans invented they were not things
that humans were born with you know and
we split off from chimps and so on so I
think these are really nice points
um
I also think they are uh I think they're
all interesting and they're all nice
points but I feel like they are
distracting from the core point I'm
trying to make here is that I was like I
agree with a lot of the high level
things like we need to build great
technology to enable a great future 100
endorsed absolutely I love technology
you know I love computers I love you
know things I want I want us to have
better medicine and a better
coordination Tech and better all these
kinds of texts like I I you know I want
us to go to the stars and to do
wonderful things of course and I agree
if Humanity continues on this path they
will not get that we are not going to
get that if we don't
improve and this is this there's a uh
the subject you're making here that like
coordination is impossible I don't think
this is necessarily true I think
coordination Tech is just something that
our culture happened to undervalue I
think there are other timelines in which
Humanity early on invested extremely
heavily into developing better
coordination technology to create to
make civilization more coherent and I
think this would work
um but it's not the not the check tree
that our civilization decided to follow
I don't think it's the most common Tech
Tree I think it's unusual Tech Tree I
think the Easy Tech Tree is the you know
Industrial Revolution Tech tree that we
did follow but I think there are
civilizations that could have gone
differently
um so I don't think that's that's the
given but now that we are where we are I
agree we we've done this is we've gone
very deep down the tech tree for energy
and power and not very far down the
coordination civilization that the
technologies that we invented to create
coherence in the society
are absolute feudalism which is not
compatible with other means of
production right now fascism
and um
theocracy
and totally disagree there is uh there
might be other technologies that we
haven't discovered yet but uh there is a
reason why we don't favor those
Technologies I completely disagree we
have a ton of coordination technologies
that do work and they're not Global
Solutions but they are a tech tree why
don't we use prediction markets for
everything right yeah yeah but like you
can you can bootstrap to buildable
coherence why don't we have better
epistemology why don't we have you know
better you know enforcement mechanisms
laws like there are many things you can
do we didn't do them and so you might
say oh X is unfeasible and I'm like yes
because our civilization did not invest
into them it would have been completely
possible to build a civilization which
much better epistemology it is
completely possible to build a human
scale civilization not with higher
intelligence just human scale with much
higher stance rationality with much
higher epistemology much better Market
mechanisms with much better truth
seeking mechanism much better
transparency mechanisms with culture and
enormous I think that if it was possible
it would have happened the world that's
not how this is exactly the one possible
world
but I just disagree then I think we're
using the word possible differently I
think like I think the when I use the
word possible I mean from like eight
obviously model perspective is that like
I think
most of the most history is random not
all of it but like a lot of it is random
like you know did Archduke Ferdinand
have to get assassinated that day if you
actually read the thing it's a lot of
wild coincidences you like escape from
the Assassin the Assassins gave up and
then he happened to turn a corner and
bump right into them like in my
conception of the world didn't have to
happen that's kind of what I mean like
it didn't have to happen like you didn't
have to get assassinated you know like
you know life bits didn't have to invent
formal logic when he did he could have
just like never been born like they're
you know this is what I mean when I use
the word which might not be how you use
the word possible I would have had a
sequence of world wars until we have
nukes one way or the other
a number of reasons uh that gave
theoretic reasons and economic reasons
and so on and trajectory reasons that
led to these developments and they're
not deterministic in a sense right there
are uh
of course there is a fundamental
question to which degree the universe is
deterministic we are talking about
models of the universe that we're
constructing that are very coarse grain
in which we say that based on these
models in these model universes uh what
are the degrees of freedom that exist
but uh when we look at the world it's
made from people and people are not that
skilled and epistemologically sound and
deterministic unless somebody forces
them to and if we build institutions
that try to maximize this then also
these institutions have a certain degree
of capture and of rent seeking and of
incompetence and when you look at our
best scientific institutions there are
unaware of very large parts of bodies of
human knowledge that just could not be
integrated in The Sciences so far
because of various cultural and
epistemological and interface reasons
which lead to a disconnect between
different groups of people in the world
and in a sense I don't think that any
society in the world has achieved uh the
full coherence between uh or people who
are smart and have sound epistemology
I think we're probably not going to make
progress on this point
um
but that's not the point Phoebe it's not
necessary that we achieve coherence
what's necessary is that we achieve a
space in which we look at the different
perspectives in an adequate way right so
obviously defined when we agree to
disagree and you say if people hadn't
make the following five stupid mistakes
or art history and instead people would
have been not accidentally unreasonable
we would have converged to a coherent
society and I don't think that's the
case well that is a society made from
people uh is as they are with their
small monkey brains and so on it's
surprising that achieve this degree of
coherence
that's fine I expect I will not be able
to convince you expect your models are
pretty deeply ingrained and you have
some pretty fatalistic models there's a
possibility that you're right but I
don't see you making a proof that you're
right so yes and so I I just want to add
the missing perspective here fair enough
I think this is really fair I'm not
trying to make a proof here I would I
was just kind of stating some of my
beliefs before I move on to my actual
point yeah like I was just saying
as a side note which I will not further
substantiate to this point my models of
reality are just way more unstable I
think there are way more ways how things
can go I think people have way more
control over reality than they think
they do I think even small numbers of
people have way more control over
reality than culture wants us to believe
us that we do I think this is various
instrumental reasons why this is that
culture is supposed like if you have
very agentic people this is usually very
dangerous and they're very unstable this
results in unstable societies I think
this is true I think my model again
you know we can talk about this more
later maybe but I'd like to actually
make my previous point but just to like
end at that point my model is is that
there's kind of like this like swamp of
low performance between you know fully
heuristic driven versus actually you
know reflexively rational and in the
middle like a little bit of rationality
is worth the no ration is then worse
than no rationality and so this creates
a national evolutionary trough where
even though the the fully enlightened
rational solution is more powerful
getting there is so expensive that it
doesn't happen very often it's very
expensive it's very unlikely to happen
and in fact Evolution will favor
mutations that go to go there
so but yeah I I do think that you could
have very Advanced cultural technology
that allows people to be very rational
to be very coherent not infinitely so of
course not you know but like I I don't
think we're at the limit of what is
possible in coordination
that being said
I do think that we're not only not a
limit we're very far from it I think if
we had more than NF1 examples of
societies of your real world history a
thousand times you know most of them
would look pretty similar to what we are
I do agree with that but I don't think
all of them would and okay but now we're
in this we're in the timeline we're in
No Escape
so what I care about is okay we're in
the timeline you're right coordination
is hard it's really hard it's a lot of
problems here if we just you know keep
going like this for another 50 000 years
like a super volcano will destroy us
totally agreed
but then I have to jump back to the
Practical level like all right give me
200 years to do alignment research not
50 000. give me give me 20 years it
could be 20 years is that a deal we can
make so like a lot of the ways I think
about how
you know how to reasonably think about
things as trade I think we should be we
should be trading on things I'm like
people you know someone comes up to me
and he's like oh look you know I really
think we should you know go to the you
know go to space as fast as possible
it's the best thing for Humanity I'm
like okay seems reasonable well I also
see all these risks or whatever you know
they seem like much bigger problem so if
you care about you know your life
spreading to the universe
and I asking if you if I asked you for
okay we never go to space well yeah then
you should say like well no that's a
terrible deal this is not what I would
be asking for what I'm advocating for is
okay let's give it like
a few more decades before we you know
build the Uber you know cyber Von Newman
Galaxy machine Galaxy eater and then if
after you know like another 50 years or
100 years or 200 years or something you
know of society progressing technology
progressing philosophy progressing all
of this and then we build the Galaxy
eater
this is what I'm saying I'm not saying
never build you know a Galaxy eater I'm
saying you know let's first make sure
it's one that we like that actually does
progress life
so we cannot give you that I can give
you this I can pause my own research for
a few decades or permanently but Society
cannot give you this what uh the uh EU
government or can give you is regulation
that up 80 percent of AI research
for a time uh
right or permanently and visit Europe
but it's or visit parts of Europe that
submit to it
or the U.S government can give you a
regulation that establishes a permanent
Monopoly for open Ai and Google on the
existing language models because the
others cannot afford to go to the
certification process but I don't think
that you can impose a ban on compute and
developing new algorithms that lead to a
self-improving agency in the near future
and unless you uh basically create some
Global institution that is regulating
access to gpus or to compute at scale
and uh so there's this B doesn't exist
and
uh it's possible that that there is a
small possibility that this can be done
but I also suspect that it might not be
desirable because the uh people that are
already of Institutions that are
currently in a position to impose that
regulation are acting not under
incentives that would lead to regulation
that is actively actively preventing
this I think it was very well
illustrated by the letter that was
written by fli Under the this
institution under the initiative Max
techmark and Anthony aguir instigated by
a alligator to impose a pause on uh
training large language models and uh
this was uh comically signed by Emet who
was uh the CEO of stability AI who did
not intend to uh to do this was mostly
thought as a public statement and Elon
Musk who at the same time was setting up
his own tools GPT
uh initiative and so it's also not
intending to
implement any kind of pause and the
majority of the people who say this are
people who are on the record of saying
that they believe that egi is a fantasy
and a science fiction idea and everybody
who was actually worried about it is a
bad person because it distracts from the
societal risks that are enforced by
language models uh uh have exhibiting
biases or disrupting labor markets and
so the reason why most of the people
signed this letter was not because they
were concerned about an existential risk
so self-organizing AI taking off and
destroying the planet for human life or
making it possible for it for us to
coexist with it in the future but there
were concerned about very other
political things and the regulation that
would have been passed by them and even
if the regulation would have applied to
large language models would not have had
the intended effect because if you tell
people you can no longer use your
existing GPU forms to uh train
Transformers on large amounts of data
without institutional oversight that
delays everything and makes it similar
to say um
cloning people or uh stem cell
technology and so on that are very
difficult to perform right now
um
right this would basically get people to
develop new algorithms is that uh CPUs
which is my paradoxically speed up the
developments that early users are
worried about
and so I think that regulation makes
sense only when The Regulators
understand the situation that they agree
on and they're globally aligned so you
don't get a prisoners dilemma situation
so a principal actor problems or the
issue that your Regulators get captured
very very early on by completely
different interests that hijack the
regulation to achieve goals that are
very different from the ones that you
want to achieve
right there a lot of people which want
to protect existing industries from
emerging technologies that we actually
all want to have because most of us
agree that uh the creative industries
that we have don't agree as employment
programs they exist to produce certain
cultural artifacts and it's beneficial
for us if we can make more of these
artifacts in better ways and if we want
to have a less disruptive way in which
this transition takes place Regulators
are being asked to do this but it's a
very different way uh argument in a
different Arena than existential risks
that we are specifically talking about
existential risk is a topic that
extremely few people right now in terms
of AI take seriously so we are already
on a very long tail of a distribution of
opinions and perspectives of the world
in which our own discussion takes place
and I agree with you that it's an
extremely important one because
existential risk is very very important
and debate in which the arguments
against existential have to be diffused
is complex and more complex then I see
most of the discussion happening but I I
don't agree that we're already in a
situation where we can ask the public or
The Regulators to impose regulation and
hope that they will achieve what you
want and not do the opposite
I believe that there is a chance and
it's something hopeful with respect to
AGI that for instance is a scenario in
which we can achieve non-violent
coherence in a society
right and one of the main reasons by
most of the ways of which we would
achieve more coherence like for instance
in covet our institutions fail to
coordinate in China they didn't but the
result of the measures that were imposed
on China was that the population went on
the street because they were no longer
willing to subject to the draconic
measures and the help visited
implementation that was necessary as a
side effect of this centralized
imposition of the zero covet policy
right as a wizard you had a catastrophic
failure of the zero covet policy and a
very large number of people were going
into the emergency rooms and died as a
result because nobody was vaccinated
right so in some sense neither of these
Solutions were optimal but imagine you
give everybody their own AGI and you
don't make the AGI authentic but you
make an extension of yourself in a
similar way as you say well from alpha
as an extension of Stephen Wolfram but
with the way that is much more useful to
everyone and it allows everyone to have
facing their own Google and to model the
world as toolsfully as mathematically
possible and that thing is your own
disposal and it's not serving some
cooperation that is forcing their
technology down your throat but that is
serving you as every individual being I
think this was dramatically level the
playing field and it basically it makes
it very difficult to lie to yourself
about the impact of your actions and for
institutions to lie about each other
about the impact of their actions and it
would allow us to coordinate and force
us to coordinate with a much much higher
degree of coherence and this is a
possible scenario where in AGI
development might indeed help us to make
a big turnaround in many of the
developments that threaten our survival
or the Integrity of our civilization new
term yes I mean yeah yeah you're correct
if everyone had a pocket HDI which is
fully aligned with human values which is
epistemologically you know extremely
coherent which does not optimize for
things we don't want which is like
deeply reflectively embedded into our
own reasoning and our thinking yes that
would be good but that doesn't happen by
Magic you have to actually do that
someone has to actually figure out how
to do that someone has to actually
develop the technology to do that and
they have to actually deploy that and
they have to do it without some other
some iak on Twitter
hooking it up with the utility function
of maximize the entropy of the
universe if you don't do that you die
yosha you die you don't get this nice
outcome for free you get this outcome if
you coordinate it if you work hard and
if you solve a very hard technical
problems that do not get solved by
default they can be solved everything
you just described is completely
feasible these are actual things that
our physics allows to happen in but they
don't happen by Magic the universe it
does it isn't kind we're not the main
characters there is no rule that we have
to make it you you talk about all these
fatalistic things about how you know
coordination will never work oh we're
always you know pushed down this you
know
track of industrialization or whatever
why would it be any different here why
would it be any different why wouldn't
it just lead us down the darkest path
possible by default and that's what will
happen by default if your model is that
people do not have control that it is
not possible to steer away from the
global minimum then yes we are
and you should go spend time with your
family until it's over you should not
care you should give up if you do think
that there are other paths that are
accessible that there are actions that
people can take if there are
coordinations that are possible to get
to the kinds of scenarios you describe
then we have to actually do that it does
not happen for free and this is what I'm
advocating for I'm not advocating this
is easy I'm not saying this will happen
I'm not saying oh don't worry the
government will fix it I'm saying the
opposite everything you say I'm like
yeah true like you're saying oh this
video game is really hard yeah the
enemies have really got hit points I'm
like yep and they have you know
dangerous attacks yep true and if you
get to the end there's a really hard
boss yep true so you shouldn't play the
game and I'm like
look the default outcome is you lose the
default outcome is you lose the default
outcome is entropy wins some random AGI
with some random ass values that does
not caracapa Cosmopolitan life on Earth
you know you know wins over or maybe
it's a bunch of them and then they all
you know coordinate because they can
actually coordinate because they're
actually coherent because they are
actually super intelligence so they can
coordinate Against Humanity and then
that's just it and it's just game over
forever
okay okay we have half an hour left
folks so I've put a call out to ask some
really good questions on the live
comments the live comments are extremely
spicy we've got a lot of I think we've
got 400 concurrent viewers at the moment
so this in the meantime can I simply
respond a little bit to Conor because I
think that we have you may quickly
misunderstanding that is important for
our conversation
um I think that my own perspective is
very specific it's a one that where I
choose my own Aesthetics and my path
through the world and the people that
interact with the projects that I work
on the bets that I make if that's
inevitable in this own perspective is
normative I have an idea of how the
world should be from this perspective
but when I want to understand how the
world is and what's going to happen I
cannot take this perspective I need to
take all the perspectives and so
basically there's an equality of
opinions and it's not a normative thing
that I say it should be a state in which
we are uncoordinated or should be
coordinated I'm just trying to
understand how the world is in this
regard and so it basically opinions I
like mushrooms they grow wherever their
space for them and the climate is right
and they will co-exist and uh so uh I'm
not upset that I exists I'm I just think
that you could oppress eak by censoring
it or canceling everybody who has this
opinion on social media but this would
not invalidate the position or the
perspective that they're bringing where
they look at a certain possibility and
you think uh it's not the most likely
out current I might agree but uh it's uh
that is not the point where the point is
that there is a variety of positions uh
that we can take and my own position is
the best possible outcome is that we are
co-existing with the global planetary
Consciousness that is basically
identifying with the regulation of uh
complexity on Earth and that is
interacting with us because it is uh not
because it is adopting human values
because I don't think that human values
are an extremely useful concept that
actually exists in the form that we can
specify and formalize and that people
would actually agree on they are more
like a useful fiction that we use in
context where we already have
established shared Aesthetics or uh we
have already constraints that uh imposed
on our behavior in such a way that this
does not really play a big role if you
don't really have an agreement on what
human values are and how to align them
and if we take this as a measure the way
in which humans basically arrive at
their values right now and how they
relate to them when they choose their
actions and implement this in AI or
emulate AI it's going to lead to
disaster I guess we agree on this right
so this notion of alignment with human
values is I don't think that's something
that works at this level of granularity
of discourse that we have right now or
also I I would disagree of being aligned
by anybody else right I'm an autonomous
agent I have mobile agency which means I
determine what's right and wrong I don't
let people around me determine whether
I'm going to be a communist or a fascist
or a Social Democrat that's not for you
to decide that's not for society you
decide I decide my values and I if about
the system that is smarter and more
Lucid than I am I don't think that I can
align it it will align it with what it
is and what it can be and so for me the
main focus is that we need to if we take
this possibility into account that we
will share the planet with systems that
are smarter and more Lucid than us that
understand the world better than us in
the relationship to the universe that
they have and they can have better than
us the way we co-exists with them is not
by imposing human values on them via
reinforcement learning with human
feedback or some other trick because
that's not going to work it's going to
be aligned itself with us if it wants to
if it lacks us if it loves us
so uh and from my perspective the thing
that is most important for us is that it
values and understands our own mode of
existence which is we are conscious
beings what's important for us is not
that we have two legs what's important
for us is that we are conscious
autonomous self-actualizing agents that
want to realize particular kinds of
interactions in Long games in the world
and I think this is the thing that we
might have to offer
to an AI that is negotiating with us
about our own Survival and I think that
requires a big cultural Vibe Swift to
have this conversation at all and I
would like to open a space for this
thank you very much so we'll go to
audience questions now actually today at
60 seconds 60 seconds you may go on 60
Seconds
I'm just gonna just gonna respond to all
that I can't respond to all that because
we just opened a huge can of worms but
human values and Alignment we could go
on for a gate so it is it is in many
forms yes yeah it is a departure session
I'm not trying to say it's not worth it
I'm just saying can't do it right now so
shelving that for the moment
I think a lot of what you're saying is
that you're looking approaching things
from an epistemological perspective
you're describing things how they are I
think this is fair enough I think when I
go into discussions like this I think
the epistemology is important but I I
ultimately in coming things from a
decision theoretic perspective I care
about winning
I care about things going well I care
about discussing how do we act so that
things go well uh if stomology is
necessary groundwork for making correct
plans and acting correctly to achieve
the goals you're trying to achieve but
it is different you can be very very
correct but very valid planning you
could also be very good at planning but
very incorrect about reality so I think
I agree with a lot of things you say
about reality I think where we're
disagreeing is potentially to some
degree on our values the thing we're
trying to optimize for and how we get
the things that we're trying to optimize
for and I'm mostly interested in talking
about that but we can talk about we can
also shelve that for a later discussion
so audience questions
okay so the the first one uh from Jonas
and this is to you yosha how did Minsky
and I know you were very good friends
with Minsky approach AI alignment
especially his concept of negative
expertise
I'm afraid I cannot really say this uh
I'm not competent in this
also I don't think that I was good
friends with Minsky I had the honor of
visiting him quite a few times in the
last year of his life and um
so uh I was part of his salons and had a
number of conversations with him and he
himself
did not think that EGA was imminent
because he did not believe that deep
learning was the right way to achieve it
from his own perspective deep learning
was a distraction from AI and um
he felt that it had been no progress in
the last 15 years
and that's uh that's a quite different
perspective right and if you look at the
implications of the Society of Mind he
saw the mind as an interaction of agents
that had a degree of autonomy and that
at the same time have to achieve
coherence he did not have the
perspective that this is what the
mechanisms of achieving that coherence
is he mostly looked at for instance
structures of management that emerged K
lines which I think can be translated
into something like Dynamic attention
heads in a continuously operating
Transformer if you want to
um maybe this is the wrong perspective
but I think it is a possibility to see
it like this you could also think about
this as something that happens at the
level of society I guess that for
Minsky's perspective existing in an
evolutionary environment and in the same
way as
the
contrails of jet planes are nature's way
of putting this particular kind of cloud
into the world
humans are Natures of a to make the
Rocks think
and impose uh Agency on non-biological
parts of the planet and there are
evolutionary outcomes of this and we can
sit back with big eyes and see what's
going to happen and it's really really
fascinating but our agency of this is
limited right if you if you basically
take out your individual hoopers as an
activist for a moment and realize that
if you are not this activist there might
be somebody else taking your place and
the fact that you are corny or Amigos is
incidental right there is of course
somebody like this has to exist and we
happen to be it and all the others exist
too and so if we if we disengage for
what we do what we think what we want
for a moment and just look out at what's
going to happen the the landscape if
that changes that means that our own
activism is distorting our ability to
make sense of the world and so if we
think about what should be done in a
world where we don't really able to
estimate all the outcomes of our actions
we might systematically impose biases in
our own modeling That clouds our vision
so I think both is important it's
important to once you make a decision
and make bets to become an activist and
say I want to build a Consciousness
research direction that allows us to
build agis that can interact with us
empathetically and that we can interface
with and such a level that the AGI would
have a chance to want to coexist with us
if we built it and we cannot avoid such
systems being built which probably is
the case and your perspective is a
slightly different one and I think
they're both valuable but let's not log
in too early on one of those
perspectives and lose the entire space
of possibilities
okay thank you very much for that yosha
a question of you Connor from hey hey
um since when did humans have good
values and are they worth saving
what is this good you describe where
exactly does it come from
oh right you're a human aren't you weird
are you going to add any more to that I
this is one of those questions where the
correct answer is just like like either
you would have to have a like
days weeks long deep dive into like
psychology philosophy or the correct
answer is just kind of like like yeah
humans have bad values that we don't
agree on humans aren't consistent blah
blah blah but also like where else do
you think value in the universe comes
from like and like even if you disagree
if you think value in the universe comes
from like
somewhere else I have things that I like
and that a lot of other people like and
we are willing to coordinate on to have
more of I like people having nice lives
I don't like people having pain and you
know if we have a few beers or whatever
we can have a long deep discussion about
like the true metaphysics of it all but
ultimately it doesn't matter ultimately
there is no
it does it's really important because
it's really the question that decides
which direction you want to go into
if you cannot justify your own values
you cannot interface with people who
have justifications for their own values
it's arbitrary there are psychopaths
okay they are human there are Christians
who are human uh the our identity
theorists who are human there are
communists that are human and humanity
is just beautiful and uh we should all
uh make sure that the AGI is having
human values this is not the battle of
the philosophy I think this question
that we supposed to you is bio important
and you cannot just dismiss it uh with
making a pun to turn I mean to be clear
I can actually do that this is because
this is as this is as valid of a
philosophy as yours it's like there is
no underlying ground truth everything is
chaos the universe is nothing it's all
nihilists I'm right you know moral
realism is a joke like it's everything
emerges from you know bargaining and
from values and from Mis optimization
stuff like and like sharding and so on
like we can talk about this if you want
to but this is not the place to have
this conversation and like so everything
has to add up to normality this is the
thing I think a lot of philosophers
forget is that everything generally adds
up to normality after you go down deeply
you talk about a causal decision
theoretic bargaining Solutions and
whatever you can go down you can get all
these justifications whatever but
eventually you're going to pop back up
to oh I don't like pain
you know you can just I can justify this
using a causal bargaining theory if you
want me to but
okay
let's let's suppose I think we could
spend two hours talking about the the
more real more realism
um Joshua a question to you and this is
this is actually a pretty intriguing
question
do you think that AGI could be or maybe
the last philosophical invention of
mankind
of course yes I mean that's the whole
idea that's uh the reason why lightness
was so fascinated by it when uh I was
introduced first the philosophy teacher
said that slightness had this weird idea
that somehow we would translate every
argument into numbers and then perform a
computation that figures out what the
right resolution of the argument is and
uh the philosophical Professor uh
thought this was a Preposterous idea and
every student in this first semester
completely understood why it's a
Preposterous idea and it's very hard to
to see by somebody like that this was
regular regarded the smart and such a
stupid idea but uh this is exactly the
idea of AI it's the idea of
mathematization of the mind and the
current iteration of this is that we
translate the argument in two numbers by
constructing an embedding space and
functions that allow inference in that
space and then we construct a new number
that keeps the outcome and currently we
are thinking about ways to build
epistemology in the systems and make
them more coherent and allow them to
combine empiricism with reasoning from
first principles
so it's really the most exciting
philosophical project there is in my
view born on and if we succeed in this
of course it's going to be better at
philosophy than us
okay fantastic a slightly more down to
earth question for for you Connor do you
think that open AI is still increasing
the power of gpt4 not through training
larger models but through other methods
and perhaps you might have some
background knowledge on what those other
methods are
I mean yeah obviously like obviously
they're making it better by any methods
they can come up with I heard rumors and
leaks about several things but you know
like most the things you'd expect for
the most part you know agents memory
context length more training data bigger
models sparsity just all the usual stuff
like nothing I haven't heard anything
that I found particularly shocking or
surprising just well you would like if I
was running an AGI lab and I was just
trying to you know speed run you know
omnicide as fast as possible it's just
the same kind of things I would do
okay okay fine um you're sure
um this is a question from APO uh you
seem to have a deterministic stance on
geopolitics uh you made some comments
about World War one and Technical
development and the question therefore
is do you see AI alignment as taking a
similar predetermined route and there
was another question we can tack on from
someone else which is to what extent is
the
um understanding of Free Will something
that might separate your arguments
that's philosophically uh extremely deep
and important question but and I'm I'm
afraid we cannot do it justice but uh
very briefly I think that Free Will is
the representation of an agent that it
makes a decision for the first time
under conditions of uncertainty
right this means that you cannot predict
that decision that you're going to make
because in order to know what this
decision will be you have to run the
universe to that point
and so you are working basically at a
knowledge Frontier of the universe and
it doesn't really matter whether the
universe is implemented stochastically
or deterministically the uh everything
that is control structure is the result
of the deterministic parts the
stochastic parts are just deleting bits
that you computed before and introduce
noise and but you don't get more free
will if the universe is randomly forcing
you this dice froze to do things then
when the universe is forcing you by this
deterministic loss to do things but the
way in which we conceptualize ourselves
is that we are systems that are made of
subsystems that are Loosely coupled from
each other and we treat these subsystems
as objects as individual functions that
interact with each other that's how we
get causality
and we don't then you think about the
world interact with the world as it is
we don't interact is the state Vector
that is describes the evolution of the
universe we just interact with the vein
which we think about the world and the
way in which we think about the world uh
history is not fully deterministic but
history is following certain constraints
which means there are certain things
which are more or less likely at a given
time and that follow from the outcomes
of certain situations right if you if a
society becomes unsustainable it's
running into a revolution and you can
try to identify the criteria for this
and the time frame for this but when you
look at down at the level at which uh
particles interact that's a very
different granularity and at this level
you will see that this is panning out no
matter what right and it's people get
very confused when they try to conflate
these different levels of description
but uh Free Will does not exist at the
level of where you describe the world as
particles it only describes is is that
where you describe the world is the
level at the level of interacting people
and when you talk about this you're
always talking about these Frameworks
about these systems in which you model
the world
thank you Joshua
um okay I've got a question in from Dr
Duggar the one and only he says there to
you Connor what is currently the most
promising path the state of the art
mechanics if you will for achieving
aligned AGI
God I wish I knew and I think we have
any current solution which actually
would like actually lead to unlined AGI
there is no I think there are people who
think they have some and you know maybe
if I'm totally wrong about how reality
works and like they get a hundred years
to work on it it could work you know
like maybe like John Wentworth stuff
um he works on like you know selection
theorems and like natural abstraction
hypothesis we said that stuff maybe
something like Vanessa coso is like
infra bayesianism pre-dca type Insanity
like
um you know I don't even think my
current research will lead to aligned AI
not AGI I I don't think Mike's my
Solutions are nearly like will lead to
that we need to come up with something
better
um yeah I think yeah a stupid answer but
I don't think any current thing will
work
okay thank you Connor um to you Joshua
uh do you think merging with AGI is the
evolutionarily favored path for most
sentient species in the universe and and
why might you think that
I think it's in relationship to uh what
chronologists that I observe in my own
family where we have very different
personalities how we learn to align with
each other
and when I want to achieve alignment
with my children how to do this or we
can also look at the way in which
species that can align with people like
for instance dogs and cats align with us
right the interesting thing about dogs
and cats is that they don't align
because they are fully coerced or
because we can program them but they are
to a large degree autonomous and they
relate to us in a particular way that
from the local perspective is rational
in the sense that it leads to a stable
equilibrium it's not when they're
smarter that they realize oh I was wrong
to align with this and it's also true in
a sustainable relationship with other
people that they don't align with you
because they are just not far enough yet
to move out and rebel against you but
because they are actually incentivized
to do so objectively in some sense it's
like it's a win-win situation if we
align and so uh this win-win situation
typically happens because we are
invested in a shared system in shared
purposes
and I think we need to build uh theories
about these shared purposes and which
conditions do shared purposes
objectively exist
the systems are set up that they lead to
stable equilibria uh in the sense that
we don't end up in a gradient that gets
out of this attractor where the systems
stay in alignment
and so I think we basically would need
to develop theories about having shared
Purpose with non-human systems and some
confusion exists because of the nature
of these systems I don't think that we
will live next to AIS in the future we
live inside of them right there will be
systems that are permeating everything
else and from this perspective merging
this AGI is already happening when you
are joining a company or when you're
joining a nation state or a civilization
you are in some sense merged with an
artificial general intelligence that
instance artificial that is being
created by intentional actions of people
and some of this is going to perform
computations outside of biological
brains and it's already happening and
they can be also in the future which is
not happening at scale autonomy outside
of biological brains and in this case I
still think that we can have shared
purposes
uh when we think about merging I do
think that there is a trajectory that is
conceivable in which the end game of egi
is that it understands itself and how
computation Works in general and it's
going to virtualize itself into all
substrates including biological
organisms bodies and brains and
ecosystems so we will find integrated
agency in all substrates
but is this agency going to be
fundamentally different than the agency
that runs on this substrate is it
possible to implement something on your
brain that is fundamentally much much
more efficient and better than the stuff
that already runs on your brain or is
this just going to be more aligned with
each other
right and I suspect it's going to be the
latter because there's already a search
process running on your brain for
looking for the best possible
organization and it has been done for
over many generations so this is more
like you need another agent on the same
substrate and you are going to a merge
with it you're going to negotiate with
it and the outcome should be that the
resulting agent is at least this goes as
a better one of you and uh
right so I think in this sense it's
conceivable that we all become like
conscious thoughts in the same mind if
we increase that integration
functionally
thank you so much yosha and I think
maybe final question for you Connor now
I actually um put your question back to
you again schmidhuber the other day you
um coined this thought experiment of
what would happen if we had a hundred
Von neumanns a thousand Von neumanns 10
000 Von Neumann's what were the the
scaling Dynamics look like and and also
I mean schmidhuber he's really really
good at things like recursive
self-improvements and go do machines and
you know meta learning right so these
things have limits don't they like when
you even when you reflect in a language
model when you recursively self-improve
there are limits so why do you believe
that there are essentially no limits
I don't believe that there are obviously
I didn't mean to put words in your mouth
but um is there a gap between you
believe that the limits are high enough
to cause catastrophe
yeah I mean of course I think so I think
there's two aspects to this there's one
is how much do I think intelligence
scales Beyond human I think humans are
like like as Josh already said like
general intelligence is like more of a
civilizational
you know scale thing and like barely a
human thing and like humans have become
more sentient and like more generally
intelligent by like memetic and cultural
development and so on and I expect a lot
of the
a lot of recursive self-improvement is
going to look like that this cannot be
magic it's going to just be developing
better scientific methods definitely
better epistemology more rational
thoughts inside of the agi's Mind more
you know structured thinking better use
of memory and so on I think there's
massive low hanging fruits here like if
you put a modern well-trained you know
yosha on a epistemological task versus
you know you know our cave ancestors
from 10 000 years ago even the cave
ancestor has the same size brain as
yosha you're just going to destroy him
at any like relevant you know like
epistemological task you can possibly
you know come up with and uh a lot of it
will look like that then some of it is
going to look like that they can you
know develop better hardware and better
software systems and just bearing
architectures very very quickly you know
the you know the brain can't really
change its architecture very quickly
there's size limitations you know the
human brain is basically limited by size
by the human pelvis and like birth and
like you know like cooling is a huge
thing like brain the brain actually has
a lot of human brain specifically has a
lot of like like unique things are like
only human brains that are mostly around
cooling
um and there's also like you know
limitation on how much energy our guts
can absorb we can't just like eat a
bunch of plutonium and take in 10
kilowatts of energy unfortunately
um so these are limitations that you
just kind of get around
um you also get you know instantly for
free because the digital system you get
things that can perfectly clone
themselves that can you know do parallel
learning that can do you know that can
coordinate amongst each other very
effectively that can you know this this
gets lots of things for free and then on
the other side I don't think the world
is very stable I think the world is
quite unstable I don't think you need
something that is infinitely intelligent
to take over the world I think you need
something probably only modestly more
intelligent than a human like not more
than 10 to the power of three one jean
Von Newman's probably 10 to the power of
one is more than enough if I had to
guess
um I think there is a limit you know at
some point you run out of energy and
like you know just like the the speed of
light becomes an issue there are
limitations to physics there is the
landauer limit there are limits to
computation I just expect those limits
are like you know just like
billions and billions and trillions of
times beyond what will be relevant like
we're we're not going to see those
limits like humans are going to be gone
way before we get to like you know 10 to
the power of like you know
six or ten jean-vonne Newman's wonderful
Okay so we've got about three minutes
left
um I just want to take this as an
opportunity to thank you both so much
for this stream it's been absolutely
wonderful and would you both mind just
making just roughly one minute closing
statements and then we'll stop the
stream but thank you so much both for
coming
okay out I don't mind go ahead
okay so I I think the NBN absolutely
fascinating point in history and I'm
very grateful of having been born at
this point
so I can experience this which to me is
one of the most fascinating things that
Humanity can experience during its run
and I think that it's unclear what the
future is going to be like but I am
quite excited for it
uh
there are many things about life on
earth that is very sad I don't think
that the default state of organisms is
they live in comfort and diverse dignity
and that we had this for a few
generations and probably have a few more
is uh very very rare for an organism on
Earth that can experience Consciousness
and at the same time I don't know if
if there is not more agency than the one
that we can see at our time scales on
this planet I don't know if for Norman
is really the Prototype of the most
intelligent being on Earth I think that
there might be a spirit of life on Earth
uh that is uh integrating in at some
level of thinking over uh what happens
on this planet to realize that life on
Earth is not about humans it's about
life on Earth
and when we extend this the systems
um or when we become the facilitators of
that transition which probably will
happen at some point in the evolution of
life on Earth that the life on earth
makes the non-living parts of the world
think too
then this is going to unlock the next
level of evolution on Earth
and this is probably something that is
very similar disruptive to the great
oxygenation event that enabled really a
new stage of evolution and a lot of the
fungi and alga that existed before this
point might not have liked that even
though that didn't go extinct but uh of
course they were reduced and many
species disappeared but it enabled
plants and animals to exist on the
planet and I think if we were to build
AGI it's going to enable things that are
much more dramatically interesting than
even plants and animals and we might be
able to coexist with it even and that is
also an amazing Prospect but the whole
thing that this evolution is happening
regardless of whether we want it or not
whether Corner tries to uh build
activist alignment and tries to impose
regulation against it's probably going
to happen and if we are not going to
trigger it could be that Humanity goes
extinct before we are able to do this
and it's being left to the next
technological species of the planet to
try again but it's probably going to
happen at some point this seems to be
the way Evolution goes and uh I I think
it's great Prospect for Consciousness in
the universe
thank you so much and Connor
yeah so I also want to thank you uh
thanks Tim for organizing this and
thanks Josh for taking the time it's
very fun I really enjoy it we could go
on for hours and hours and hours
obviously you know barely scratch the
surface here like you know in another
life you sure would have been my
favorite you know mid-centuries 28 it's
with 20th centuries German philosopher
uh if you had been born a century
earlier uh it's great stuff I love it I
really enjoy it but uh like again
I I care about actual practical things
for the most part philosophy is for me
entertainment's more so than it is
actual things that you know actually
need to get done so
the the thing I would end on is It's Not
Over
I don't believe in this fate in this
kind in this way I don't think that like
this is a healthy morality for a
decision-making agent to have I think a
decision-making agent should actually
make decisions and actually try to try
to lead to an outcome that they like I
think we can get to the outcomes that
yosha likes because those are outcomes I
like too you know like living side by
side with you know beautiful nice AGI
wow that would be awesome unfortunately
I just think you don't get there by
default this is not the default
trajectory this is a very non-standard
trajectory for the universe to go down
this is a very very very non-standard
thing to happen it is possible and I
would like us to get go down that
non-standard directory I think it's
possible I think it's it is possible I'm
not saying it's easy I'm not saying I'm
going to succeed I expect not to succeed
I expect no one to succeed I expect that
yes by default the universe just goes
down the you know most likely paths it
doesn't mean others don't exist so that
they're not accessible and so I would
like to focus on actually doing the work
and getting to those things but anyway I
want to live in if I want to live in a
future where there can be Yosh you know
writing this wonderful Philosophy for
centuries and I can read all of it
wonderful okay
um it's been absolutely amazing to both
of you now we have another live stream
tomorrow with Connor and Grady Butch uh
Grady booch gave the touring lecture I
think about 12 years ago and is a real
heavyweight in the software engineering
and computer science world so
um we've got that to look forward to
tomorrow but thank you all so much for
joining the stream I really appreciate
it and I hope to um welcome you back on
the show as well very very soon yosha
thank you so much for coming thank you
very much for facilitating this